[Music]
foreign
yes
yes I can
[Music]
foreign
what's going on guys you should hear us
just fine I hope so okay I've been
working on this program okay I think you
hear us just fine King speak
yes everything sounds fantastic it works
just fine now
so what's going on on Earth Lords we're
back again for another week you know we
got a a pretty hectic show for you guys
you know definitely go out on Twitter
and and tell the world we're live tell
them that we're here talking let me read
it because you know we we want we want
to get around man we want everyone to
know that we live but anyway KK what's
what's going on King I'm chilling I had
a good day so far so far today is
fantastic I haven't got a chance to
brush up on some shows play some
fortnite with the sweaties uh Gerald the
Rivia is available now uh as far as his
quest goes and
um yeah
soon as you land you're getting killed
is it that bad it's that bad we were in
a match I've never finished 49th in a
match
49th we might have to jump on that
um yeah I'm pretty much uh I've been
playing the Harry Potter game
I haven't played it today because I'm
trying to do better on streaming in
general wow yeah I just had so much
stuff I had to do today I I literally
haven't stopped doing like I think I got
like an hour of a power nap and then I
had to get up and do this
so me too uh appreciate everyone for
coming through uh you know
what's what's up down anime we got a lot
of talk about today man first we got to
get the business out of the way we got
we got some patreon questions King we
got some pictures what's up patreon
questions love those yeah so um let me
bring them up real quick we got a
question for Pixel bit G y'all should
dive into that Netflix Ragnarok show I
actually watched three episodes season
one
I I just seen the Thor in what's his
name fight and
[Music]
um
and then I started watching the other
fight of the uh the biblical character I
don't want to like I yeah yeah that
character fight I haven't watched it yet
but I just started that fight well I
watched all the season one before and I
watched all the season two of binge
watch season two right after
um I've started watching season one over
again because my wife didn't see season
one but um yeah uh pixel bit uh I
thought the way they structured the the
fights and the way they gave you a
history and the way they flesh the
characters out to fit The Narrative of
their Universe I thought it was
fantastic because you know like I said I
like that modeling model combat stuff
and you know a lot of times Humanity
doesn't have a chance but when uh you do
the ball Lander with uh Valkyrie you're
able to use their powers to get a Divine
object that can uh hurt the Gods I
thought it was a master class in coming
up with that concept and and pushing the
boundaries in in that whole you know uh
humans versus Gods you know it's it's
dope it's a dope thing yeah so it was uh
it was definitely good man it was good I
really enjoyed it what's up
uh probably gonna finish I I'll watch
the first season hopefully by the next
podcast so you know we'll we'll really
go into it uh okay right now
just certainly haven't had a whole lot
of time man but you know I have a
feeling you know this this week's gonna
get a little bit uh gonna get a little
bit hectic but so you know we got some
stuff to talk about today I guess we'll
talk about the homework for uh first so
we do have stuff to talk about when it
comes to
the
Attack on Titan then watch it remember
we got to do a reaction show
oh see you uh you don't want to talk
about up to the point you're right now
oh yeah okay
um but I did that last time that was on
IOP okay that was on IEP
and also I'm waiting for the name of
this cartoon that I saw if um
if uh if I if I die I love you if
something should happen I love you if
something should happen I love you
um and it's on Netflix right
and you
know my wife is texting me I'm like yeah
give me the name I think if something
[__] happens I love you and it's about
it's a 12 minute cartoon
and nothing uh made me cry you know put
tears and Minds put put feels in your
heart it's a you know parents
you never wanna
you never
want to bury your children right and
this cartoon is about
um it's a very big question it's about
parents dealing with the loss of a child
and how they started suffering in
silence and they were separated apart
they're sitting at a dining room table
and the distance apart could be miles
away basically and it's a breakdown of
you know you're sending your kids to
school and
we trust him that they're going to come
back from school every day and we we
take it for granted
and um
you know that day uh you know
unfortunately
I guess the person was writing from a
place of hurt or a place of empathy uh
for the people that uh lost someone in
Columbine on any school shooting and
which is terrifying as a parent when you
when you hear something like that so I
thought it was really good it's
something that you should see uh it's a
silent film
so but it has a large range of emotions
and the storytelling in the cartoon is
incredible so it's called Uh in case
something happens I love you and it's
absolutely amazing absolutely amazing
so
um
he said the homework I was watching yeah
the whole book I was watching is called
you oh well so so we're done with the
attack on Titan because you you wouldn't
do a little bit on ILP but you didn't go
wrong oh yeah okay yeah yeah sorry that
that cartoon really got me so all right
the attack on Titan
so they they remember they were running
in formation and they had the big female
Titan chasing them right and she's
chasing um Aaron right and
she wants him for some reason I don't
know why she wants him but he knows that
she's behind him and he says you know
like if he bites his hand he can turn
into a Titan because he can fight it we
could do this because she's massacring
these uh the the scout team the survey
team as she's going she's just like
killing them and he's seeing all these
people die and he's
and Levi's like you trust the plan but
Levi give some choice
he said I'm not going to tell you what
to do
but you know whatever it is you know
stand on your square and the rest of the
team is begging him yo listen yo just
you know trusting trust in the process
trusting you know the boss trusting the
captain
and they captured the Titan and the
Titan is is like um she's in this
position blocking her neck blocking all
her final parts and they keep shooting
these
um these uh like these Hooks and to hold
it in the position and they make sure
they shoot enough to keep her there so
she can't move and then you know Levi's
standing on top of her head and Levi is
talking mad junk to her like we're gonna
find out who's in that neck it
and I'm like oh my God they're gonna
find out who it is because I'm curious
as hell to find out who exactly it is
and one of the girls that was inside the
field heard the screen because the the
big titan let out the feet the scream
the female Titan see now at the scream
and the girl like she was like oh God it
says Shivers up her spine and she's like
why why uh she said that's the sound of
a wounded animal that has nothing to
lose
and all the Titans started coming and I
knew it was like a like a rallying cry I
thought it was going to be like a
rallying cry
they get their Nick tearing it they're
not paying anybody any mind they're just
trying to get to her get to her like
secure the package get the football and
they all get them I mean I took a big
little and small they all lit and they
proceed to eat her
I did not see eating her was an option I
thought they was gonna you know tear off
the the shackles on her no they were
going to eat her and I'm like you know
what that kind of makes sense because if
they do eat her they can just poop her
out later and then she's back in you
know Titan form or whatever
but
as they're leaving
the captain calls you know for retreat
everybody you know run back
to the to formation
one of the dudes
that's down with the survey team
is just like Aaron he's just like him he
can turn into a Titan and we have a
triple changer in the mix this this show
keeps taking the norms and flipping it
on top of his head because I thought it
was just Aaron was there but apparently
somebody has the ability to change and
don't change but I don't know what's the
end goal what's the goal here so added
um told me to stop watching and
everything after this is gonna be a
reaction on a patreon so we want he
wants live reactions to it because I'm
gonna tell you I'm not gonna lie
my reaction for that part where that uh
the the regular Hunter killed a regular
you know I mean a regular survey team
member killed another regular survey
team member
blew my mind and I was like I just can't
believe this is happening right now
because that wasn't an option in my head
so
yeah so he's holding me back until we
can actually get to that part dip Down's
like yes yeah so I I got I did have a um
two more uh uh two more questions I
apologize I'm it's new it's new doing
these patreon things it's going to take
me a minute to really incorporate them
into the show good so we got another one
uh we got a dip down he says addict
First Impressions on chainsaw mind to
interest you enough to watch more take
care guys yeah I'll be watching more
um
I still not hooked
but at this point
I I want to give the show a fair
opportunity so I'm still going to watch
more but I I like the concept I think
the animation misses at times it looks
weird but I I like the concept uh then
someone said how long do you think it
will be before we see the uh Destiny
related shows movies or anime from Sony
and Bungie
that's that's to both of us you said
what how long do you think it would be
before we see Bungie Destiny anime TV
movies how long you think before we
start seeing those I think Destiny's on
Deck I think they're probably in on
production on that uh Halo anime
um don't they have a couple uh no no
just destiny
oh yeah yeah
it should be
um it should be really soon that thing
is like I heard that was like in the
cooker for a minute but then
with the success of the live action
um Whatchamacallit uh uh Last of Us it
can really go to that they can really go
to live action if they if they want to
keep it true to form so I would go with
cartoon yeah and um dip down this other
question I don't really want to ask it
because I do I I don't think it's
relevant right now where he is in the
show
and I don't want to ruin anything for
him if you get what I'm saying dip down
like I could ask it and I think he could
answer it but the question it comes down
to that is right now you haven't seen
enough of this character for him to
really put them against each other uh he
it's he's kind of wanted like who you
think will fight in a win in a fight
between two characters but I don't think
you've seen enough about one character
to really justify that fight you know
what I'm saying yeah all right so
um we're going to uh move on with Attack
on Titan yeah you know I think next week
we'll have some stuff going for you guys
so
you you you had some some homework you
you did have some homework it was first
off King told me he's never seen you and
it's the Netflix show
you so he's never seen you so I was like
King watch two to three episodes of you
you know really
give this show a chance because uh
season four is about to come out and you
know we're gonna go into that on
the fact that you is so popular right
now because every time you comes out it
really gets into the the moment and King
hasn't seen the show up until now but he
has seen a couple episodes now King give
your honest opinion and your honest take
on you season one I don't know how many
episodes you watch two to three I
watched two I was gonna watch the third
one
um
um but you told me it wasn't necessary
at the moment and I said you know what
um I'm definitely going to probably
finish the season with that out of the
way
he is my
like prototypical form of Superman
um he could be a little bit taller I'm
talking about the actors the actor that
plays Joe oh so you think he could be a
Superman the reason why I believe he can
be Superman is because the way he's able
to blend seamlessly into any uh
background he's undetectable
unnoticeable and forgettable easily
forgettable right he's just not like The
Stereotype that white dude like yeah
well he he he is he is how Superman's
supposed to be I would have him eat a
little bit more probably put on 15 more
pounds of upper body uh you know keep
them still the same lean but um and also
when I will shoot the shots I will shoot
the shots as him looking taller than he
actually is like they do with a lot of
these uh actors but um he is Superman
um because you know Henry Cavill can't
blend in a crowd if Henry Cavill was
inside that soup uh that uh the bar he
would stand out but this guy is in the
bar so he's getting his stalking on and
he doesn't have and out but all right to
get to Joe and to get to um Guinevere
back
he says it crazy one of your back
because he's
I love his imagination being that he
reads so much his level of imagination
and deduction by looking at somebody and
trying to figure out their world is so
it's so crazy
I love how he looks at every little
minutia of the person or their
surroundings and the things about them
that he extrapolates and he and he turns
them into his personal little game his
personal little stories
um at heart so far I didn't see any
atrocities that he was done besides the
fact that he captured
um
Gwen's uh uh well miss Beck's uh fake on
and off again uh druggie boyfriend
um
but he's he's at the heart of it he's
like a real decent dude like he sees a
kid and you know he gives him books and
he
tries to
um Shield him from the world because the
little kid is dealing with isolation
from the moms and and the step pops and
uh uh verbal abuse if not physical abuse
um from the the step pops slash
boyfriend or whatever that is so uh he
tries to share that Shield that kid and
give him a safe haven
so he's not all that bad
but when you when you see him trying to
get him get to know this girl
um he's obsessed over her to a point
where he's trying to cultivate the
ultimate person that he feels that will
do good in her life and would help her
Elevate at the same time he sees the the
boyfriend that she's dating uh on again
off again druggie boyfriend
um as a detriment and a barrier to her
but when he has a conversation with the
guy after he captures him because he
hits him upside the head and he captures
them and he's doing all types of stupid
things over the social media and I'm
gonna I'm going to explain how that
doesn't make any sense in his day and
age but
the guy explains to him who she really
is and the reason why he hasn't made it
past uh the friend phase with her was
because she secretly wants a bad guy she
wants the bad guy she wants to be taken
to the dark area she's enamored with the
dark areas so her friends all hinge on
that dark grifter area whereas she
doesn't because she's The Working Girl
out of her whole team her whole team is
affluent in money uh Prestige she isn't
that right so she's trying to uh front
like she's in this group she hangs out
with them but she can't afford a lot of
things she purchased a big gift for a
friend for a birthday that she couldn't
really afford and her other friend
realized that she couldn't she tried to
tell her you know stop doing these
things and you you're not about this
life
but also she was being propositioned by
her professor so she had a dynamic there
and she puts herself in bad situations
that she doesn't need to be in she makes
terrible decisions in men in a life in
general and especially with money
because she's always behind right but
this guy feels like he can be the savior
of her that's what I see so far I like
the dynamic that they have there but
again I saw a little bit of empty holes
there that should have been filled up by
the writers right
this guy one keeps the guy around
downstairs that's a liability you have a
drug infused Dude down in the basement
you leave him alone
um I'm sorry you'd have left me in the
outer broke out of it I think hold on
let me I think the reason that I'm
willing to overlook that a little bit is
because Joe is a narcissist in a lot of
ways he's got a lot of narcissist
Tendencies and it's not mainly on his
personality it's how he perceives
everything and he thinks he's never
going to get caught you know what I'm
saying like he thinks he's above ever
like he's ahead of everyone so to me he
feels like he's the store owner he feels
like he's in charge of everything to me
that would make sense someone that that
is that that's full of himself would
think that no one would go in that
basement because he's not telling them
go in that basement that's true okay so
please explain to me the reason why he
feels that it's a smart move to use the
email address that he used to get the
guy to come to him now anybody knows if
you're a detective all they're going to
use is pull up your IP address now he
doesn't look like he's a smart enough
dude to use a VPN he doesn't have any
social media presence but at the same
pro at the same uh token he used the
email address is going to Ping from
place to place now
I don't know how he rerouted uh the
messages to look like he was uh texting
from someplace else uh but at the same
time
this guy is still using uh text from the
dude phone he puts the phone in his
bathroom
anybody could track your phone be like
what is going on here I got an iPhone
tracker uh you know for my kids who got
the iPhone I don't have but I also have
a phone tracker in my Galaxy so I can
actually find where my phone is if I
leave it you know
um it's just weird I just think I guess
later on it'll probably be cleared up
because the phone is going to probably
become a problem and it should become a
problem and it should be a talking point
but I'm a seat but um I thought I was
gonna drop it because I'm not into the
stalker Vive stuff yeah you was
definitely not feeling when I talked to
you but yeah he's
at the moment
he's he doesn't
come off like that he comes off as a
dude that is very detailed and wants to
be in a situation but some girl popped
up at the party and was like yo I
haven't seen Karen she just mysteriously
left all of a sudden so I don't know you
know maybe he made her disappear too but
I'll figure it out as I go along but so
far you
you got me
no pun intended
yeah so here's my thing when it comes to
it oh and he's actually a a sick pervert
to even uh touch yourself outside that's
kind of crazy yeah that was just like
this dude is wild crazy he is one of
those people
that is bad in every white shape or form
but you're but throughout the seasons
and through more uh like you understand
like how his mind works he's like damn
like I want to like Joel but I can't
like you know what I'm saying like it's
just I I I I'm a huge person for
narrated shows like when you narrate
over the actual show itself like Dexter
did it Burn Notice I like when the the
main character narrates what's going on
his mind while the show's going through
and that I think that's the reason this
show like really like captivates with me
is because I I really enjoy that because
I feel like he gets context to stuff
that you can't actually know what's
going on like and what I like is like
you think that oh this this just some
weirdo creep you know some weirdo creep
but then the first episode ends How It
Ends let me oh okay he's not just a
creep okay
and what's funny is it's like I said he
he got narcissist Tendencies like he
generally feels what he's doing is right
because he's putting himself all around
this this
uh gwynier Beck chick and he feels like
unless he does the all actions that he
does
she's never gonna be her full potential
yeah but her friend seems to be on to
this dude
um from the start like from the start
you you in the same place that's kind of
convenient type of thing
um but and you could tell like
Beck has friends
that are selfish but she does have one
friend that is a very selfish individual
but she actually does care about that
like she's been what the one that gave
it a check yeah yeah she because she's
like look like you know you could tell
when she's talking she's a very
self-centered person but when she's with
back she's like look you like one of my
only friends like one of the only people
I can rely on well she know that she
doesn't want nothing from her
yes you didn't want to take the check
from at all you know she wanted to
continue to do the the program in school
but the you know the creepy ass teacher
felt like you know but I mean he pulls a
cart too because you know she was
wearing sheer shirts you know flirting
with him to to kind of stay inside that
program that could pay for her
um uh Whatchamacallit shout out to 108
Dragon TV
um pixel bit G everybody that's here
shout out to the 38 that's here thank
you for showing up
um we only got 22 likes let's finish
that guys please fix that
um but um yeah it's you could tell she
uh she didn't want to do anything with
this guy she was leading them on to get
her grades and stay in her program so I
I just feel that um
that was a little bad on her part it was
terrible you know what's funny too like
this dude is a scum in all sense of the
word you know
but they give you a good thing it's like
this dude's a creep
but the but they don't make the people
he's doing this to innocent you know
what I'm saying like and I like that
because that's how the real world is
everyone's got these skeletons in the
closet like everyone and but I'm curious
to we we have to get back to this man
because if you think just two episodes
is crazy that show gets absolutely
insane like season three is just weird
it's just crazy because because I what I
will say is Joe Finchley fights someone
that can imagine that's all I'm gonna
say that can match his energy you know
what I'm saying that craziness that can
match that tip world thank you for
hitting that like button lessons brother
yeah so you know I'm very uh because
when I talked to you earlier I honestly
thought you was gonna drop this like uh
yeah my wife came down was watching it
with me
yeah it's definitely a good it's it's a
good uh couple show I watch it with
Grace she's she's she's seen this and
and you know she's like oh okay she's so
she's like oh why how they got you
watching this and I'm like um well it
came out 2017. so I'm pissed off that
it's 2017. yeah well the new Season's
out right now so but I like the
character I like the guy so much he
sucks that I can see him as Superman see
when I see when I see you know um I'm a
weirdo right like I see uh different
characters you see them from others too
and other stuff like I'll be I'll be
casting them in different roles like
like how I'll take you and I'll put you
there I'll take you and I'll put you
there like the guy from Never back down
I thought he was going to be such a huge
star he's the same dude that was inside
violent night the fake actor that
couldn't make it that was uh married to
the sister and he ran off from them when
um when the The Mercenaries came a
minute took everybody hostage and he
bust out the window he said Hardcore
Parkour bust out the window I thought he
was going to be the next Brad Pitt I
would have staked my life on that
he did something and pissed somebody off
in Hollywood and he is not that guy but
uh shout out to 108's dragon with the
five dollar Super Chat hey I thought
this was uh King David and Alex show who
the hell is this guy laugh out loud I
want attic back ASAP laugh out loud and
he got their new cut baby cut the little
girlfriend wasn't really acting like it
was a choice at that point so yeah it is
what it is but yeah I'm glad you like it
you know Joe is definitely one of those
characters that she's just like I want
to like him so bad at this moment right
now I like him
at this moment right now
I like them because
how he cares for that kid he sees
himself in that little boy
you know um and when when when the step
pop slash boyfriend came out
you know he was like man I can really
hurt you
uh I can really really it gives bro
Dexter Vibes this have you ever seen
Dexter no I never watched Dexter and
this show because the Dexter is about a
serial killer killing serial killers and
like this isn't the same type of show
because uh you know he's not exactly in
the same scenarios that Dexter is in but
what I will say about this individual is
he gives off that that Persona where
Dexter refrains from acting out all the
time like he'll come across though
because Dexter has like I don't kill
innocent people unless it almost gets me
to get caught you know what I'm saying
that's the only time he'll cross that
line and obviously this dude don't care
but you know
he he you could tell he doesn't want to
do it but he had a lot of trauma in the
past that he crosses the line so fast
and he doesn't realize until he crosses
it well when he gave the guy
um The Peanut uh latte
me personally all he had to do was Crush
our peanuts and put it inside the dope
that he was giving him he would have
killed him instantly
um but the fact that he gave him in a
latte
he didn't want to scare him yeah he did
he he wanted to see if he had a peanut
allergy he's like oh he did he was
telling the truth
um
but he was really backed in the corner
in that in that instance right there he
was back in the corner that he couldn't
get out of he had to
really
decide if he was going to release this
guy and he was untrustworthy dude he
couldn't you know it was going to go
left but I think and I don't know if I'm
wrong I hope I'm I'm not I hope I'm
right
that he can once the guy you know they
find his body he can leave him the
laptop and find uh where he killed the
the college kid and The Hazing thing so
that she can be like oh he's truly
repulsive I really don't want to have
nothing to do with him and I really
want more in his passing type of thing
but I just think it's a bad idea I can't
wait till you get later on man because
there's a point in the show where they
try to make you feel bad for Joel and
they do a good job at doing it like it's
just like it's like come on man give my
give my dude your break and you can just
come forget all the nonsense he has
pulled off like well yeah that stalker
thing he's really heavy in it but he he
can blend in perfectly I like his blend
in style
it's really good so
we do have another show
it is uh
this movie's interesting
uh you know King was very adamant about
uh me trying it out and what movie would
you guys think I'm talking about I'm
talking about a movie that's called
shotgun wedding
some pretty much shotgun wedding is
Jennifer Lawrence uh I don't know
Lopez uh Jennifer Lopez she and this
dude is getting married and pretty much
the mayor the the wedding is being
sieged by Pirates I'll let you take it
off King because you're the one that
made me watch this me all right yo so
um it was on Amazon Prime Mom it's on
that right now yeah it's on it's an
Amazon original yeah it just came out I
think it was on Friday and I had saw the
trailer for it probably like a month ago
and I told my wife I said oh yo your
girl is in a movie and um it's on Prime
you know so we ain't got to pay any
money for it yo it's a watch she
definitely gonna get a watch from us so
um
she's watching it and I cannot stand
Jennifer Lopez's character in this film
I cannot stand her character her
character is uh it didn't it didn't make
sense it was it was too it felt like she
wanted to be brave at one time she
didn't want to be brave like
she she was a self-centered uh character
and this guy was trying to please her in
every way but he was broke he's a
baseball all right so a groom the groom
to be the groom
is um a baseball player he's in his 40s
and you could tell that he struggled
from the minor leagues and stuff like
that and he happened to get cut right
before this so his money really isn't
all that good Jennifer Lopez father is
really affluent his wallet is really
good and he wanted to pay for the
wedding all right so the whole thing is
they go to the Philippines
my wife was really pissed off because
she knows I want to move to the
Philippines
um so they go to the Philippines and
they find this island that is
inexpensive and he can have everybody
over there the groom does and she wanted
something small so he was going to
accommodate her small want and his big
grandioso a feeling of showing
expression of his love and everything
that is that's happening is an
expression of his love all the stuff
that he's trying to do
well somebody was invited to the wedding
a gate crash it was invited to the
wedding by the the father and Pirates
take over now apparently pirates in the
area come and they raid but they go in
they go inside the hotel room steal
stuff and they leave but these Pirates
started taking hostages and started
taking names and started doing things so
started making people wonder like what
the hell is going on with these you know
Pirates these Pirates is you know acting
a little bit out of order a little bit
different but they were organized
I don't want to really you know spoil it
too much but
you know Jennifer Lopez finds her her
inner uh we'll go a little bit longer
and then I'll change it to the spoiling
so okay you know she finds her Inner
Warrior the husband
um her groom
uh finds his his Warrior he's always
like that remember he's an athlete so
um
I guess he's looked upon to do athletic
stuff but again remember I'm telling
he's a 40 year old athlete and you know
he just wants to bond with his wife but
they have unresolved issues so during
this whole movie these unresolved issues
start to become resolved when they have
to work together and she sees how much
that this guy has went out there to to
prepare the wedding to hand craft little
pineapples and put little lights on them
to put little notes inside things and I
think those little things is missing
from relationships nowadays I mean you
look over at your significant other and
are we going the extra mile for them you
know
um are we trying to listen to that was
significant other I know as us guys I'm
guilty of this a lot as as me I can't
talk to every guy
I don't probably say thank you enough or
I don't probably acknowledge enough oh I
probably don't listen enough so this
movie kind of centered me into yo you
know what start listening more start
being a little bit more attentive start
you know uh trying to figure out what
that other person wants and you know you
y'all can bridge the gap because he
explained to her that you know she was a
scared uh little girl and she she said
you know pretty much the same thing
about him and they understood in that
vulnerability those moments right there
that they were actually a team and he
became a team to actually uh you know
finish off the the movie and get to a a
good resolution but as a team they
weren't going to do it separately and he
tried to do it separately and it wasn't
going to work
um but as a team they were actually
pretty good and that's what I liked
about the movie
oh you know without getting to the
spoiling stuff
I felt like they look this is something
you guys can definitely watch if you
have Prime uh you know I would say watch
it if you like these this type of movie
especially you know uh Jennifer Lopez is
in it but like to me
I like it but I feel like there's better
movies that have a similar type of
feeling like Bounty Hunter uh I feel
like that was a better movie sure that's
an ex-husband and a an ex-wife but I
feel like you know there might not be
the same type of thing but they give a
better a better delivery like for the
most part like I just felt like this is
just two random people somehow they've
got free from okay let's let's do it
let's go in the spoiling room all right
because
um I have no clue why my stuff's popping
like that but it's okay I'll fix it so
you know when we talking about this
particular thinking like what is your
opinion on you know just the overall
story
well it's
the typical JLo fear you know um man
it's girl girl it's man uh Happy Ending
hahaha Jennifer Lopez along a Whimsical
way
um
it it really isn't a good film
right in the heart of it and it really
isn't a good film because of her
right I think uh another actress would
have did better but like uh don said he
came there for to see Jennifer Lopez
I'm not gonna lie
that woman is in a level of shape
she is she she is she ungodly she's an
ungodly shape
um kudos to her for for getting into
that shape
um 100 percent
incredible incredible
but again
like you said you didn't know if she was
going to be weak if she was going to be
strong they kept switching like they
would establish parameters of the movie
and I don't mind if you switch it up a
little bit like they have that moment
but it's like every five minutes they're
having a moment yeah and it's just like
I just didn't like it man I just did
like I I started watching because my mom
was here when I started watching like
mom come here watch this with me and she
went she was in the living room after
like 20 30 minutes
yes he couldn't take it she couldn't
take she couldn't take Jennifer Lopez's
uh whining I couldn't take her whining
her whining was driving me up the wall
it was like totally like like nails on a
chalkboard you know nothing that will
make sense how how did Jennifer Lopez
not hear the bullets when they came in
with the fully automatic weapons because
they're not far from that beach and they
came in that that beach and they were
shooting it in the air how'd they not
hear that like I don't know
it was like I said there's a lot of plot
holes in it
it's it's a funny film I didn't see the
the double switch up at the end
yeah yeah I didn't see that I seen the I
seen the other switch right I I said
that I called it from the beginning I
said this was this way and this happened
this way I don't want to spoil it for
you because listen anybody who got
Amazon Prime and I'm pretty sure all of
us here got Amazon Prime because of
prime you can go check it out for free
you know go go go check it out if you
have nothing to do you want to sit down
with your girl you want to show her that
you're a caring loving guy you know sit
down there watch your wedding your girl
probably enjoy you know sit there it's
like I said it's it's not the worst
movie in the world but um yeah I
wouldn't even you know okay let's let's
let's give them all right what are you
giving this popcorn one
yeah I'm giving it a one too
it was just oh my God man like Look it's
even hard for me to sit here on this on
this podcast and tell you guys to even
give it a try like you know I personally
probably will never touch this movie
again and I'm not gonna lie when it
ended and I was leaving my room I was
like thank God that's over like
because I originally the same thing huh
I said the same thing yeah it's just you
know I think Jennifer Lopez probably one
of the biggest issues in the movie that
could have replaced her if a couple
other people and I think
depending on how the scripture went I
don't know if she
was the one pulling for all the
cryingness or was it the writers that
was wanting her to be like that uh but
it is what it is you know I don't think
you guys should watch this King says you
know try uh you know it's like I say if
your girl wants to watch something you
know Valentine's Day
yeah Valentine's Day right around the
corner man that's right Valentine's Day
listen listen guys take a cue from the
the groom in the movie
he had attention to detail he listened
to her he was giving his 100 all in this
film I'm not gonna lie he gave his all
look at his that his attention to detail
tour listen to her and actually do it
yeah so you know that's what we said man
you got guys go give it a chance I don't
think it's the worst movie in the world
uh but at the same time
I think you guys could find something
better to watch yeah
all right so
we get we we know what time it is
we know what time it is
it is Last of Us episode four
recap you know we're gonna go over the
episode in great detail
uh so King do you do you have any
opening scenes you want to talk about
anything in particular that you know
well first off let's just go over the
overall narrative you know uh put it on
the balance obviously because I don't
care what anyone says I'm still gonna
compare it to the game uh you know
people that sit there they'll say well
addict if you wanted to play the game go
play the game
um the same people are telling me that
are the same people that was
giving it a pat on its back at the
beginning of the show during episode one
and two because they said it it was a
really good show because it was almost
one for one on the show but then they
start gravitating off and now those same
people are telling me go play go go play
the game then I had it so to tell me the
overall perspective of this episode
buddy
all right so we get get a chance to see
um
Ellie starts off and she's
messing with a shiny new toy
a gun
and she she knows how to pull a gun she
knows how to load a gun she knows how to
clear a chamber
and In These Quiet Moments you have this
perception
of what you believe you would do in a
given scenario
with your gun
so she's playing these scenarios in her
head while she's looking at mirror but
also
Joe's out there and she's making sure
that she he doesn't catch her with this
um this gun
and she tucks in inside a book bag and
they're going in the car and they're
going across country and in the car you
know um
she find you know she has a book of um
old dad jokes you know and they're
playing music and they're driving
and they come to an impasse where they
either have to go around and you know
Joe doesn't want to go through the city
because if they can go straight through
this tunnel they can get to where
they're going to go to without going
through the city
every apocalypse world and every movie
every video game it's almost like a law
don't go in large areas yes they start
out stay out of areas where people have
advantage over you like the advantage
like the same thing when we when we play
um
fortnite
if somebody has The High Ground on you
to be honest with you you pretty much
out of luck so a lot of times you know
people will have The High Ground you you
want to stay out of those areas so they
uh get to going and um lo and behold
they run into humans
now Ellie has never encountered humans
on the outside of the wall because Joe
has been telling her you know these are
I mean the clickers and the the infected
people are terrible but the real problem
is the humans the real thing that you
have to look out for is the people
and this is the first time they have
this encounter this is also the first
time that Ellie has to use her shiny new
toy
um
and
there's trauma there it forms a new uh
trauma cycle there and she had let
something uh slip to Joe that you know
this wasn't her first time that she had
to do something and I guess we're going
to delve deep into that aspect of it but
you can see
um and Joe and Ellie because they they
give jokes back and forth and
you know he's uh coming around to our
he's uh he's warming up to the idea
uh that she's a person
and not just cargo because he called her
cargo
and I'm pretty sure that that kind of
hurt her feelings
at that moment but um
they're they're
sort of kind of becoming a little tandem
a little bit of a team
and the world is I guess is going to
where you wanted to go to attic as far
as you know start to see more of these
encampments more of these people more of
the stuff that we run from in the video
games and we we use our pistols on so we
we're starting to get to that aspect of
it and I think this episode
um shows what happens to a dystopian
Society where there's no overarching law
and you have people looking out at one
person as like the law Giver because
when they got back to the encampment
um she was like judge jury and
executioner when it got to and I'm
talking about the person that was in
charge uh you know she when it came to
deciding somebody's fate right
um because if if I'm correct that was
the only doctor in the town yeah see
that that part that logically that made
no sense made no sense at all especially
if you've survived 20 years in the
apocalypse let's go ahead and get to the
spoiler part right you know we talked
about five minutes you know let's get
into the spoiler part okay so this is
the part of the show is if you didn't
see the episode and you're planning on
seeing the episode today or tomorrow or
whatever you just didn't get off of work
I suggest you just uh run away from this
show and uh check it out um on our um
other channel
that you can check out the shorts and
you can check out the the episode
and it's parts and pieces opposed to you
know seeing the whole thing so you don't
probably don't want to see you or you
probably don't want to hear about the
wedding
um shotgun wedding well you can just uh
watch the episode of The Last of Us for
um recap so
yeah okay let's go
the more I watched the show the less I
like it wow I felt like this show
first off the
the
the Ambush was
was nowhere like it was in the game
right you know the only the only common
thing between that and the ambush in the
game is they crash into a store yeah
like like because I I just
they're making Ellie
into a crybaby that can't hold her own
ground right oh Joe get in the wall get
in the wall
in the game they pulled Ellie out of the
truck and Ellie fought them with Joel
and it's just like look like you know I
get it I do I I feel like they're doing
things this way because they don't want
Gore in the show for some reason because
that's the only thing that makes sense
to me because if you really look at it
and you think about it
they haven't really had Gore in this
whole show no they haven't had really
violence in this show whole show episode
one singing violence
like a lot of stuff happens off screen
I see episode one
Grandma ain't going chow chow on the
dude right that's literally the only
time you've seen anything like that
right in the whole show
you know in a show about an apocalypse
you've seen the zombies AKA whatever
they want to call them
infected fungus infection I don't care
what you call them they've showed it one
time and we're on episode five coming up
this is going to be five going in the
next week right episode two
they seen a little bit there but for the
most part it was just Joe punching that
dude you know what I'm saying
they didn't even really show him
punching him it was like one of those
things where he threw him over his hands
back a little bit didn't see it episode
three there was literally almost no
violence in episode three there was no
this is supposed to be an apocalyptic
world and I feel like I don't feel like
it's about to licked world you feel like
Disney made it
yeah actually now you mentioned it it's
just like when I saw that ambush
I'm like it just feels like they don't
let me shut this I don't know if you can
hear that or not but it just doesn't
feel like
they're not trying to put it in a
violent tendency and that's why I
personally feel like episode two when
the infected came in and they kissed
homegirl
that didn't really hit me but now that
I'm thinking about it why would you
change from soldiers coming in there to
the infected coming in there right it
makes no sense but if you really think
about it now after we after we've
watched a couple more episodes
oh they're taking a lot of the human
interaction out like oh because then you
would have to have killed the humans you
would have to have shown the Carnage on
the screen that and I think about it
when Joe has killed people in the show I
haven't seen like he killed he shot
someone from a long distance range and
then he shot someone off camera that
panned and showed him on the ground
right
and if you go and you look at the actual
game
Joe has took Joe has thrown people into
glass almost decapitated them Ellie has
done the same thing and they haven't
they're doing us such a horrible job
portraying Ellie in this game in this
show it's it's unreal so do you think
that the okay and I felt they did they
disnified it right
um
violence is being is taking place but
it's taking place off screen like when
Joe had to kill uh the guy I think what
was the guy named Ben or something like
that that was on the floor Brian
or something you know a non NPC
um and you know the guy's begging for
his life and he tells Ellie to go inside
while he you know kills the guy but he
kills the guy off screen then they bring
the body later so
see there's ways to tell stories
and there's ways to tell stories to to
reach a broader audience
I think the story that's being told in a
video game is a story that can't be told
to everyone
but I think the story that's being told
here
it can reach a broader audience
without releasing the shock Factor you
can still tell the same story without
needing the shock factor that you're
looking for and I understand where
you're saying from a purist standpoint
The Last of Us is a dystopian world that
is it is black or white you're either in
or you're out there's really no Shades
of Gray right there's this kill or be
killed and this is it and the fact of
the matter they're not handling like
that they're handling the world as the
Shades of Gray
and I know you're pissed off with that
aspect of it because you want the black
or white it's not that I want the black
and white I want the show to feel like
they're an apocalypse world
and when he was laying in the bed there
was it was happy when he was going to
sleep it doesn't it doesn't feel like
this game is not this game started to
break it to you guys this movie this
show
is not supposed to be happiness is not
supposed to be you know grateful there's
times where they get that moment with
the giraffe in the game and stuff but
for the most part this is a depressed
this supposed to be a depressing
experience it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be a very
very down
experience it's it's one of those things
where you're not supposed to enjoy you
just it's entertaining you if that makes
sense
but because they're not apocalypse
that's one of the reasons people stop
watching The Walking Dead because they
put to a point in The Walking Dead where
it did not feel like an apocalypse
anymore it felt like just unique
circumstances going on from point to A
to point B and then they would throw the
apocalypse to the middle like always
sprinkler it was sprinkle there you go
to the apocalypse view the apocalypse
for you everybody good no not you but
you get them apocalypse like the whole
Show's supposed to be centered around an
apocalypse and this is how these
individuals are surviving
so
how do you feel about the interaction
between Ellie and Joe like um do you
feel that they're growing close as a
team or he's trying to understand her or
she's getting closer to understanding
him as a person I think that part
they're doing a decent job you know I
think they could do better but I do
think they're doing a decent job in that
matter
um you know that's probably the only
highlight so far of this show like it's
gotten to the point where if it wasn't
for r r probably would have dropped it
after this episode I wouldn't have
watched next week I mean okay so I I
will say that this is probably the
weakest out of all the episodes
I thought this was the weakest one
because it was too much
Dead Space like when they drove to the
encampment and they went sleeping in the
forest
um I thought that was dead space uh when
they were driving I thought that was
dead and if you think about them
sleeping in the middle what did that
contribute to the story what did that
contribute nothing nothing my wife said
why the hell are they outside and not
sleeping inside the car like and and I
get it
I I I I I get the whole thought process
to it
um
I just feel
that they disunified it
and HBO is probably trying to reach a
broader audience they're they're they're
probably trying to
reach an audience where you can have 13
and above watching this
um
I'm tired of that though man I get it
and I know why they're doing it but I'm
tired of companies developers game
developers movie directors trying to
reach your broader audience so they just
screw the entire show up and look it's
going to be successful it's Last of Us
the overall narrative is still good
regardless how you put it the overall
narrative is good but it's just like
they're in an apocalypse so we ain't
seen nothing even remotely violent for
the most I felt like apocalypse it
really it feels like like one of those
scenarios where they're like an
abandoned Town yeah you know what I'm
saying everything was crazy is even when
she shot the doctor
they didn't show that camera they didn't
show that either right and this is from
HBO h b o okay so do you think that HBO
this politics here
right they're losing to Disney
so do you think that HBO says
we have to adopt the Disney way to get a
broader audience
the Disney way is not the reason people
are losing to them they own Marvel
you're not winning against Marvel with
just one or two IPS you can't compete
with an engine like Marvel where you can
consistently get people to watch
something they don't care about because
they want the overall arcing storyline
that it goes in the in the existing MCU
storyline
I'm tired of people wanting my
people want Destiny money they don't
have Destiny products people want GTA 5
money they don't have GTA 5 products and
now people want MCU money but don't have
an MCU product
I feel you
I I I I
was like they're making it more
accessible acting like that's the reason
Disney taking everyone's lunch money
that's not the reason Disney's taking
everyone's lunch money but it's the
reason it is but it's not the reason
Disney's taking everyone's lunch money
is because Disney has spent the past 10
to 15 years building this universe to do
what they're doing all right question as
a CEO you're the CEO of HBO right
do you put an R rating and and give them
the gore and everything
and limit your audience or do you go
with the rating that they have now
to get more eyes on the product
I'm just
it just depends okay like if you're
looking at like a CEO kind of thing you
know you do have to look at the overall
perspective of the type of content you
can provide right so if people don't
like this they might not watch whoever
the show Runners make the next show et
cetera et cetera you look at what you
saw when it come to Game of Thrones
right people pretty much boycotted those
show Runners I know people to this day
that won't watch anything though showrun
is right because they try to rush the
last bar of Game of Thrones out to get
out to me
just Last of Us isn't going to get you
the kind of success that you want sorry
to tell it to you the only type of way
that you're going to get that MCU type
of success is you have to have an
ongoing story arc that other game other
movies and shows build onto the last
kind of like what DC and Warner Brothers
trying to do right now with James Gunn
during the beginning stage is going to
be in the same universe they're going to
you know expound on the universe
um
they're building something here and we
know what HBO HBO has like they've done
The Sopranos they've done long-running
shows they've like you said Game of
Thrones do you think the reason that
they're not trying they're trying to be
as casual as possible because they know
this is a Sony product this is off a
video game that we have no hold up this
is off a video game that we have two
games of so we have a season two
we don't know where we're gonna go after
season two
I can tell you why they're not doing
anything crazy
child
and a child killing or
being threatened
in the climate that we're in now
doesn't play well
I failure
because they could have did that same
scene that you wanted with Ellie
fighting for her life and killing
somebody
it doesn't play well but that's how
that's that's what the there they're
taking I get they're taking someone as
iconic as Ellie she was really good in
the first one really good I think she'll
be a lot more aggressive in the second
season hopefully but because but
I would feel like you
and I told my wife because I showed my
wife that I I'm gonna play the last of
us too
and The Last of Us won just so my wife
could see the game
because I like Abby
right if they mess Abby up
I'm done
I'm like I'm done done like done I guess
to me
I'm like you you're taking someone as
iconic as Ellie someone that was very
stubborn
but would listen when it counted very
aggressive but what what would be there
when it counted and she she was kind of
like a hundred percent on the paddle at
all times but she knew when a light
wouldn't let the paddle go okay and it's
like you're taking someone like that
sure did she need Joe in a lot of
scenarios and Last of Us yes but you
could argue that she helped Joe get out
of his money issues that Joe helped her
get out of in the game let me ask you a
question all right because it was a
point someone hold up hold up people
keep saying in the chat budget this is
one of the most highly budgeted shows
that's ever been in TV it is it's kind
of crazy
um
it was a point
where
she grabbed the knife
or she can grab the gun
in that moment you knew exactly where
HBO was with it
is if she grabs the knife you're going
to see visceral violence you're gonna
have to see her get her hands completely
dirty you're going to see it
but
they chose the gun
and you you know off air shot pow
one shot too if she she didn't shoot the
guy in the head to finish something and
I know a lot of people that's like hard
uh hardcore of guns like
if you're in a scenario like that and
you're inexperienced a gun she probably
would unload a whole clip on him right
so I say this
I I feel I feel your intense
anger at
how the the sisifying
Ellie where she's a she's a stronger
character
right I feel they're really making her a
support character they really are and
she's not a support character to be
honest with you right I said she's like
the main character to be honest with you
um
we we see the reasons why I really
believe honestly it has everything to do
with child violence and they're not
really trying to exploit child violence
so
maybe season two when but I don't think
they're gonna show on-screen violence
anyway I feel you but here's my thing
HBO is very
known to have violence they don't care
they had uh they had Arya and Game of
Thrones killing people and she was
definitely a kid listen um
do you think that is this HBO or is this
Sony
I think it's a bit of both
I'm thinking of Sony I'm gonna be real
with you like we've seen them slowly
like let up on the violence I'm really
thinking it's Sony because HBO's got no
problem putting their characters in that
kind of light well you're right because
in Game of Thrones when the mountains
squished that guy's head and popped his
eyeballs out his head you know that was
visual violence when they burned
somebody on camera when they kill people
and they decapitate decapitate people
but they had on spikes that that was a
visual violence when they did the Red
Wedding and stuff like that they that's
visual violence and that's on screen you
know happening
um
you might be onto something bro you
might be really really hitting the nail
on the head it might be a Sony uh you
know uh edict that they don't want to
have on-screen violence uh happening
because it might be nil's there on set
you know maybe he I don't know he
doesn't want to to go in this Direction
with directing I don't know but all I
know
is do you think it's Pascal
I don't know I don't know because he's
like the Mandalorian there isn't any
violence but it's a Disney show though
yeah but okay so listen hear me out
really really quickly right hit me up
he's still got contracts to the
Mandalorian
that's an infinitely bigger contract
than it is for Joe
and he says and I'll do this that in the
third you'll really want me to be this
character but
I can't really be having my character
associated with x y and z
then at that point
that is HBO and Sony
for denying him the right to be that
character and finding someone that could
socialize himself with it because it's
like look
at that point you're valuing
having him as Joe than Joe B Joe right
and to me I can't get down on that even
if he's the better Joe which I've that's
Pedro Pascal though I mean that the name
man the name ring bells right now man
that's the Mandalorian bruh
yeah let's be real here ain't nobody
knew he was a million dollar in for like
until he stuck his face out so listen
listen all right
I don't like the dude right I'ma tell
you the truth man because I think he
messed up my Mandalorian and I wanted
him off I said you know recast them be
honest with you
he did the same thing in the Mandalorian
he want his face out
he could say yo you ain't gonna mess up
my my mind Mandalorian Disney bag
I don't want to be doing this all
violence you know come on let's keep it
clean you know my name is clean
I don't know man I think it's both I
honestly believe it's both
what are you doing man hey you know I'ma
still watch it obviously uh because I
gotta cover it every week uh but it's
just
and then they're putting like this
random chick that just kills a doctor
for no reason and I'm just like I get it
you're upset but if you're a community
leader you would not kill one of the
only doctors if the only doctor you have
in the community I thought that was
idiotic I thought that was idiotic um
any medical train uh technician anybody
that can uh any Engineers any Architects
we know at the end of the collapse of
society those individuals would be
highly coveted you know those people
will be protected so I believe I thought
that was idiotic and uh ill-advised as a
as a leader I would have never killed a
guy and the fact that the guy said I
brought you into this world like I was
your doctor I was your
I'm like
see oh she offer rocker but she's off a
rocket anyway because she thought it was
this guy that was out there uh bringing
in Mercenaries and killing and he had
nothing to do with it you know that she
blaming everything on this one guy
but okay excuse me
what do you rate this episode bro
I give it a three
I'm with you I thought it was the
weakest out of all the episodes that
they put forth whereas I came from a
five from last episode
um I think I gave the episode before
that of four and I think I gave the
episode before that before I think this
is a three and it can easily became a
two
um
but we don't give halves I'm gonna give
it a three just because I like the team
bonding and a character building of the
characters uh we're getting to learn a
little bit more about uh Joe we're
getting to learn a little bit more about
Ellie and them uh you know coming
together as a unit
um they got their first confirmed kit so
I don't know man um like I said it's a
three for me but
that's the only reason why but I think
this was the weakest one out of it
because I felt empty at the end of the
the episode so
off of four episodes where would you get
the popcorns right now
for the whole I will give it four oh for
four episodes I will give it a four I
mean um the strength of episode three
the you know the the sticking to the
script in episodes one and two
um I told you I was like kind of weirded
out by the kiss of the the weird thing
that that didn't make any sense to me
um but this episode actually brought the
score down from it would have been like
a five but uh the strength of the other
three episodes holds it at a Ford for me
I'm a
I'm Eva three all right what up math he
said I like the joke but I like the joke
book too he sit with the with the with
the um scarecrow standing in the field
oh Dad I think I've just got to the
point with the show where
it's like the Halo show you know no
every week let's come together and see
this Fiasco because I think it's getting
that bad it's not as bad as Halo but
it's definitely getting up there like
it's getting at least at least Halo had
some form of they're in an award with
the Covenant and you uh you understood
they was in the war with the Covenant
like to a point people would forget what
the hell this show's about
one more week okay we'll see one more
Friday Friday you you know it's Friday
right oh it's Friday yes because of the
Super Bowl they moved it from Sunday to
Friday oh that's dope all right that's
dope listen my teams are not playing so
I don't care two two craps about the
Super Bowl be honest with you my team is
home and they've been home you know so I
root for everybody to lose once my team
lost everybody loose so that is when it
comes to the last of us you know um
I thought the show was okay this week
but I don't feel like it feels like the
last of it it feels like a generic Zone
a zombie apocaly I gotta find out
um because what I'm trying to do is I
want to find out what's the show that I
wanted you to watch
and um let me get that show but uh I'm
gonna finish more you
some I'll be returning with that uh this
week we're going to get up
um the Titan uh um Attack on Titan Live
Well
it's gonna be the patreon so it's going
to be recorded yeah it's like I said
um you know you guys want to go to the
patreon uh you know I'll drop it here in
a second go there you can ask questions
to us every week you can get live
reactions and I wanted to make it you
know accessible in a lot of ways that's
why you know I I seen some of these
people putting these episodes that like
the same kind of Tears we have for like
15 20 bucks a month and I'm like nah we
ain't doing it seven bucks a month will
get you all the reactions and 10 will
make you dictate what we react to and
the reason yeah uh the reason we're
doing that is because like you know this
is free but if you want
first off to to sit there on my shoulder
watching me watch uh chainsaw man that
first off that that's killing my vibe
because I can watch it sitting on my bed
but I don't I gotta watch in this in
this chair
and uh you know a lot of you liked it I
saw some comments uh you know I I think
you guys are gonna like what we have in
store for you like I said uh there was
one person asking about Cog and solve
here's the deal with Cog and solve when
it comes to reactions it has to be
something small like a five ten minute
thing something it quick in and out it
can't be something that they can't watch
episodes at all like if you wanna you
know if you want to like yo have Cog
watch The Rock Lee versus gar fight
Naruto Okay I could probably pull that
off but if you tell me yo half Cog
watched the first season of Naruto he
gonna say y'all don't got time for that
it's not gonna listen
r r with the Lords is um Lord attic and
myself because
we're a little bit more flexible
all right
um the other Lords are busy at this
moment but soon that won't be the case
you know hopefully everything will get
freed up around that period of time but
when others is doing one thing the other
two start doing something else taking
care of the other things and before when
I'm really busy you saw a cog in these
streets so again
he'll get to something maybe you might
see uh uh a fight like around in a good
UFC fight to have Cog react to that you
know that that'll be some combat talk or
whatever or you see me talk
you know I'm thinking about things that
I can do for combat talk
um that can revolve around the patreon
being that my medium is live action and
me interacting that way I can go to an
old fight like Ronnie Lyle versus Ernie
Shavers or I can go to uh Floyd
um versus uh Gotti one of those fights
or whatever and I can give you you know
live reaction to one of those rounds
for combat talk something dope something
that y'all can and maybe in that tear
you can pick a fight for me to go back
and reminisce about and talk about you
know and I can do a live reaction on
that yeah
I thought it was bringing up you know
when it comes to call and solve
if you guys want to react something it's
gonna have to be small and that's if
they agree to it you know uh Cog said he
don't mind reacting as long as it's
small and he can get in and out in like
10-15 minutes and you know uh there is a
couple things that you know people
mentioned but right now let's just have
me and King learn how to do this
efficiently before we're bringing up
anyone else doing this stuff uh so
appreciate it for coming through man
king uh first off we got 56 people in
the chat hit that like button hit it I
absolutely
do it hit that like button share it out
please man why don't you like me hit the
like button stop playing
but you know I appreciate it for coming
through is uh what's going on with you
King this week uh this week um nothing
uh I'm going to I gotta finish up a
couple of things I gotta ship out a
couple of statues uh and I told you
dudes
um Mom video games I'm not really trying
to talk about it here
so uh three statues for PlayStation uh
VR too
oh that's it I'm not trying to give him
any money yeah and I I put in the in the
chat there's the patreon that you guys
go sub to like I said the five dollar
tier you know that's the one that most
people sub to you'll be able to ask any
of the the show's questions at the
beginning of every show seven dollar
tier you can watch any reaction we do
I'll I have three more episodes that I'm
about to post of Chainsaw man hopefully
me and King will get together and we'll
do a couple episodes of Attack on Titan
so we're gonna keep you guys busy we'll
keep you guys busy there'll be plenty of
content in there my goal by the end of
the month is to have the whole first
season of Chainsaw man up there yeah
here I have the whole first season of
Chainsaw man and I'll probably have uh
the remainder of this first season of
Attack on Titan and uh getting into
season two and all that other stuff so
we can be ready for when the new season
of Attack on Titan shows up
but that's pretty much it is guys you
know down there hit those links hit that
like button man okay I got to get those
likes up and until tomorrow on the attic
show King will be there we're gonna be
reacting to the Nintendo show it's
probably you know tomorrow's the
Nintendo shows yeah so lit so we're
gonna have the we're gonna walk we're
gonna react to the Nintendo show then
we'll have a post show obviously and
we'll probably
minorly talk about some of the things
going because it's kind of dry right now
it's not a whole lot going on this week
so we'll talk a little bit about other
stuff but for the most part I I said
we'll be in and out of there in an hour
hour and a half we gonna have some
special guests on with us tomorrow too
yeah so appreciate it for coming through
and until next time this is gaming
addict
and and um David what
peace peace
[Music]
foreign